- À 300 kilomètres au nord,
un peu de chaleur.
Pour la première fois
depuis le début de la pandémie,
la communauté de Tuktoyaktuk
Des retrouvailles attendues
depuis longtemps dans ce petit
hameau nordique isolé de tout.
(rires)
des mesures de confinement,
il y a quand mêmeuand mêmeuand s
preoccuaptions dans
la communauté. Tuktoyaktuk est
la plus au nord des Territoires
du Nord-Ouest.
D'ici s'étend l'océan Arctique,
la frontière du Canada avec lais
ici, on parle de l'importance
de mieuxde mieuxde mieux surveix
protéger cette frontière.
2000 km
qui nous sépare de la Russie",
dit le maire de Tuktoyaktouk.
Même si la communauté de 860
inuvialuit, presque tout
le monde russe dans
de caribous et des baleiniers
de toutes origines qui, qui, qu,
au hasard des déplacements
de leurs proies, se sont
"J'ai moi-même du sang russe,
j'espènt que ce n'est
le sang de Poutine", dit-il.
(rire)
un endroit stratégique pour
la suiveillance deillance deill.
Le Norad y a installé, pendant
la guerre froide, ce site
de radar qui fait partiedu syst.
Ce systeme compte en tout
47 stations de radée réparties
dans le nord du Canada.
Université de Calgary
- L'ensestème de
détection et de radar  qu'on
avait mis en place après
desuétude. En ce moment, des
usses pourraient lancer
des missiles balistiques contre
le Canada dans leur propreune
capacité de les détecter.
- Le gouvernement canadien
a récemment octroyé un contrat
l'opération et l'entretien de
ces radars, mais ça prendra bien
plus.
- Ça veut dire que ça prend
des nouveaux satellites,
ça prend des nouvers,
ça prend des drones qu'on puisse
déployer dans le nord,
ça prend des nouvelles bases.
C'est un investisse
5 et 10 milliards$.
- À 150 km au sud de Tuktoyaktuk
se trouve la municaplité
d'Inuvik, un autre emplacement
de choix station de réception
satellite assure de bonnes
communications et la
transmission rapide
aménagé l'un de ses quatre
emplacemés
d'opérations.
C'est l'installation la plus au
nord exploitée par le Norad,
À peine deux ou trois personnes
y travai
peuvent tout de même suivre
d'ici à peu près n'importe quoi
poursuit-il.
Pour intervenir du haut des
d'Inuvik a été aménagée pour
ir des F18, mais ce
n'est pas tout à fait au point.
Il doivent utliser un câble que
la piste est encore trop courte.
Et quant à la capacité
de véritablement aterritoire, le
maire soulève des inquiètudes.
"Il faudrait être fou pour neq.
La présence militare est très
limitée", dit-il.
À la fin des années 80, les
forces armées ont démantelé la
Inuvik. Le quartier général de
la force interarmée
se trouve à Yellowkife, à plusd.
C'est de là que sont dirigées
les opérations des milieu
éloigné  qui assurent une forme.
C'est une vaste région où il n'y
a pas de menace militaire
commandant du premier groupe
de patro
nt une
Les Rang
présence 24-7 et s'ils voient
quelque chose, ils le rapportent
colonel Raymond Chiasson.
Pour la desd-Ouest, ld-Ouest, ls
discussions sur la protectionn'.
Mais elle est bien consceinte
que l'in
Mais il y a plus que l'Ukraine
climatiques les eaux de
navigables sur
une plus longue période, il
faudra être prêt à y pro
Elle a écrit à Justin Trudeau,
qui s'est engagé à en discuter
avec les premiers ministres des
Et politiquement c'est un bon
moment pour le faire.
international est instable pluse
public et plus la volonté du
public à accepter des dépe
Le gouvernement canadien at icie
d'opportunité pour développer un
argumentaire, un d
dépenses militaires et voicipou.
À Tuktoyaktuk ce soir, lapopulae
cette joute poilit
Ici comme à Inuvik, il importe
de  démontre sa so
Et en levant la tête vers lecies
boréales semble être un présage
porteur
Ici Va